et on à guillaume martin est avocat
membre de l'observatoire parisien des
libertés publiques
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous
alors d'abord on voit que ça a été une
manifestation qui s'est bien déroulée et
le plusieurs milliers de personnes qui
se sont rassemblées et cela alors que
l'on on l'a appris en tête est relancé
sur les circonstances de la mort adama
traoré il fallait manifester aujourd'hui
c'est important selon vous je crois
qu'avant c'était important de manifester
commémorer j'imagine à la demande de me
suivre je suis travaux et surtout je
crois que cette année cette fois d'une
ampleur particulière compte tenu des
rassemblements qui ont vu depuis joué en
10 juillet qui sombre se focalisant
autour du cas là dessus je me suis
traoré est juste à mort mais opposant de
manière générale mais question des
violences policières dans ce pays alors
s'agissant des nouvelles investigations
que faut-il en attendre selon vous je
crois que ce qui est intéressant ça va
être de voir quel peut être le sens qui
va être retournée me pose est comment
dire à l'amour du travail oui quatre
nouveaux médecins qui ont été saisis
est-ce qu'ils trancheront en faveur des
médecins qui n'ont jusque là comment
dire on est si musicalement tu travaux n
est pas lié à la période
d'interpellation de celui ci est ce
qu'ils ont dans le sens de la thèse
qu'il a lancée par la famille nous
verrons espérons qu'ils renvoient aux
qui sera dit permettra de mettre un
terme définitif à ce débat et je pense
que ça va si le travail est sérieux mais
il ira dans le sens de la thèse de la
famille
c'est un subtil qui ont lieu en août il
devrait en tout cas qui sont annoncés et
puis à santés aussi des investigations
qui vraisemblablement non pour l'instant
ne sont toujours pas ordonnée et
principalement la question de la 2de la
reconstitution de l'interpellation
monsieur traoré amoudé bible nous paraît
essentiel en tout cas c'est ce que ce
que dit la famille et je crois que c'est
assez incompréhensible de l'extérieur en
tout cas de l'épicier assez
incompréhensible pour l'instant on leur
refuse cette reconstitution à l'armée on
est en présence de tests sont
radicalement différentes
s'agissant des faits se sont déroulés il
ya quatre ans et quatre ans après les
faits les juges d'instruction ont confié
la semaine dernière une nouvelle
expertise cette fois à des médecins
belges
c'est plutôt inédit comme décision oui
ça c'est étonnant mais ça en dit long
sur oscille à la commande et à la
difficulté dans ce dossier de détail est
une réalité de vérité en cabinet médical
peut-être que le grec que ce soit ni des
médecins belges on peut espérer qu'il
sera comment dire un film où sévit dans
un sens dans un autre et est donc que la
décision qui le rendrait le rapport qui
le rendrait soient indiscutables
nous verrons tout à 1 306 trancheront
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya eu jusqu'à
présent des l'aider notamment dans les
rapports qui ont dévalé les gendarmes
un certain nombre de choses qui étaient
le discutable le disputer et ce qui est
bien en tout cas il faut le noter c'est
que les chansons ont jugé utile de
saisir de nouveau des médecins présents
a pu aussi d'en refuser donc malgré tout
les choses avancent dans cette
information judiciaire et je crois qu'il
faut s'en féliciter
ça avance lentement ça pourra avancer
plus vite
espérons que ça elle maintenant assez
rapidement des conclusions d'ici la fin
d'année le petit je ne sais pas alors
vous dites que ça avançait lentement
est-ce que c'est d'une certaine manière
le résultat du travail effectué par le
comité emmené par un la third adama
traoré assa traoré
oui ce que les récents des lots
dans la sphère autres à haut risque mais
aussi à la mobilisation de ce comité et
puis à l'écho que grandissante de la
route cette mobilisation rencontre parce
que au-delà du cas de la mort de m
intéresser les violences policières
c'est un problème récurrent dans ce pays
qui est posé il est clair que cette
mobilisation a porté ses fruits
il ya également aussi le travail de des
avocats de la famille qui sont un plan
strictement judiciaire
amen et juge d'instruction doit modifier
ou en tout cas à accélérer nos calories
de 2,7 de cette procédure et tous s'en
féliciter la constitution est déjà
longue
c'est normal que la procédure prennent
de son temps en essais sont graves que
les responsabilités soient bien
déterminé ceux ci et dont on peut
craindre en tout cas c'est ce qui a été
dit notamment par la soeur de lamine
traoré que des huit génériqueurs qui a
été un peu ici dans cette procédure
peut-être les tentatives de mettre tout
ça dans un placard et de référence la
clé en espérant que personne n'est qu'en
tout cas là la famille adama traoré
reste quand même à méfiante elle dénonce
une instruction impartiale
d'ailleurs à ça traoré appel un procès
public
que faut-il entendre par la république
il faut davantage une institution ceux
qui sont actuellement désigné ou
peut-être d'autres sujets entendu
qu'elle appelle accusations des
magistrats qui sont actuellement en
charge de dossiers convenu à ce qui est
effectivement des charges peut être
retenue contre les gendarmes et renvoie
ses 92 bombe devant un tribunal et là
évidemment il y aura un procès qui sera
qui sera public comme qui les possèdent
tous les procès en france
ce qui est clair c'est que à l'évidence
il faut que les choses soient débattues
on parle d'un procès public le fait
qu'un qu'une instruction qui narre à
vancouver par socke celle même secret
d'instruction est gay mais plutôt un
régulièrement étalés sur la place
publique mais il est clair que sans
doute cette affaire
son procès où chaque partie on sera de
ces policiers s'en expliquera un débat
judiciaire aura lui et puis ensuite une
décision un jugement sera sera prononcé
je pense que c'est c'est ce qui est
souhaité par la famille je pense que
c'est ce qu est ce qui est souhaité par
beaucoup de gens en tout cas les
personnes notamment qui était
aujourd'hui en la même station merci
beaucoup à vous alliez au martin pour
tous c'est précisément celles que vous
êtes avocat membre de l'observatoire
parisien des libertés publiques